and we're awaiting the arrival of James
Comey he left his home in McLean
Virginia about a half an hour ago CBS
News contributor ed O'Keefe is the
Washington Post's congressional reporter
his front-page story this morning
explores how the Comey testimony could
turn congressional probes on Russia
toward the question of obstruction of
justice and possibly impeachment he
joins us now from Capitol Hill ed good
morning I saw your piece right there on
the front page of the Washington Post
it's got that headline you know did the
president obstruct justice right there
that's the question so what would
constitute obstruction of justice well
it would essentially be examples like
what Comey is suggesting here and
perhaps a more methodical attempt by
either the President or those close to
him to try to impede the ongoing FBI
investigation the initial read of this
from from legal observers and from
senators who've been monitoring this
closely suggests that he didn't
necessarily obstruct justice or there's
no evidence of that just yet but
everyone seems to agree he was certainly
untoward or improper in making these
kinds of requests to the director but ed
what do you make of Chris Christie's
theory that listen he's a political
novice that he said some things that
were he described it as a New York kind
of conversation that he didn't really
understand the significance of some of
the conversations he was having do you
buy that you know on-the-job training is
an excuse or an explanation we've heard
from supporters of the president for
quite some time but I think you know if
you look at polling if you talk to
lawmakers up here there's really no
tolerance for that at this point and I
think that today may indeed confirm that
that was all it was but that is going to
be seen again as I'm Congress and in
fact as you know a demand there's an
expression that lawyers use called
ignorance of the law is no excuse right
exactly
what's necessary though back to the
question of obstruction of justice
what's necessary to make what we have
heard obstruction of justice what is the
missing element here intent for
something else we have to see intent for
sure you'd have to see more evidence of
it whether it's those recordings that
the president says
that he had made or that there may exist
some other documents or somebody at the
White House would essentially have to
come forward and say I was asked to do
this to try to step in and to try to
influence things and again after months
of this so far as members of the
Intelligence Committee and other
committees have said there's no smoking
gun that suggests it's that but you know
there may be other potentially serious
charges like abuse of power that come up
and I think it's important to remember
today is not about ending this it may
not be the significant turning point it
is one key player in this whole affair
sharing his thoughts
remember he sought out this opportunity
he wants to do this publicly and explain
himself and senators have an opportunity
over a few hours really to lay it all
out and get him to answer these
questions and his answers may lead to
something else some some of absolutely
yeah absolutely I know you've done an
analysis of many of the senators who are
on this committee because there can be a
breakout moment for a senator I'm
thinking about like you know back in
history and you know Joseph McCarthy
hearings when when senator Walsh said
you know have you no sense of decency
those those kind of questions can
produce these historic moments
absolutely and I think that is what adds
to the intrigue of this the line is
literally out the door and I'm two
buildings over right now we'll race back
to my seat in the room the line is out
the door
there is an eagerness to see this I
would keep an eye guys on a few people
James rich who you had here earlier will
probably be one of the staunchest
defenders of the President or at least
be a little more critical of Comey and
his behavior in this whole situation to
others to watch Marco Rubio because you
know he's a past and potentially future
presidential candidate and another at
the end of the diets for Democrats
Camilla Harris the California Attorney
General now senator who has talked about
as a potential 2020 presidential
candidate big opportunity for someone
like her to introduce herself
essentially to the world as they watch
this it's similar I think to what
happened back in 2007 when then senators
Obama and Clinton had a chance to quiz
David Petraeus about the Iraq war and
really set the table for their campaigns
potentially somebody in the room has a
chance to do that today
and speaking of hearings in the pad in
Watergate was the famous remark by
Howard Baker what did the president know
and when did he know it
right and we'll see we'll see what we
get yeah here is what it would be today
but you know certainly if you read
Combes prepared testimony is a lot of
people appeared yesterday we were all
spellbound by it this is a guy who knows
how to dramatically testify to lawmakers
so he will not disappoint today most
likely do you think this could have
lasting damage add between the White
House and Congress today I don't know
that I think yesterday's hearing frankly
between intelligence officials and
members of Congress may have had more
damage than today because Comey is now a
former government official there's real
anger on that Intelligence Committee
which met with Dan Coates and the acting
FBI director yesterday they all refused
to answer questions about their
interactions with the president in
public and and chairman Burr and other
members Republicans and Democrats alike
made very clear they were upset about
that and they don't like it and they
don't want them to do it again if it
happens repeatedly in the coming weeks
and months I could really throw down
some divides between the White House and
Congress and thank you it's a slippery
slope because I get I think that
President should be able to have secured
in private conversations with their
aides unless they are you know deemed
appropriate and that's a little bit yes
yeah absolutely sir